dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir reinforcement
learning is a technique in the field of
machine learning to learn how to
navigate in a labyrinth play a video
game or to teach a digital creature to
walk usually we are interested in a
series of actions that are in some sense
optimal in a given environment despite
the fact that many enormous homes exist
to discuss the mathematical details the
intuition behind the algorithm itself is
incredibly simple choose an action and
if you get rewarded for it
keep doing it if the rewards are not
coming try something else the reward can
be for instance our score in a computer
game or how far our digital creature
could walk it is usually quite difficult
to learn things where the reward comes
long after our action because we don't
know when exactly the point was when we
did something well this is one of the
reasons why google deepmind will try to
conquer strategy games in the future
because this is a genre where good plays
usually include long term planning that
reinforcement learning techniques don't
really accelerate by the way this just
in they have just published an excellent
paper on including curiosity in this
equation in a way that helps long-term
planning remarkably as more techniques
pop up in this direction it is getting
abundantly clear that we need a
framework where they can undergo
stringent testing this means that the
amount of collected rewards and scores
should be computed the same way and in
the same physical framework open AI is a
non-profit company boasting an
impressive roster of top-tier
researchers who embarked on the quest to
develop open and ethical artificial
intelligence techniques we've had a
previous episode on this when the
company was freshly founded and as you
might have guessed the link is available
in the description box they have
recently published their first major
project that goes by the name Jim Jim is
a unified framework that puts
reinforcement learning techniques on an
equal footing anyone can submit their
solutions which are run on the same
problems and
a nice bit of gamification leaderboards
are established to see which technique
emerges victorious these environments
range from a variety of computer games
to different balancing tasks some
simpler reference solutions are also
provided for many of them as a starting
point this place is like Disney World
for someone who is excited about the
field of reinforcement learning with
more and more techniques this subfield
gets more saturated it gets more and
more difficult to be the first at
something that's a great challenge for
researchers from a consumer point of
view this means that better techniques
will pop up day by day and as I like to
say quite often we have really exciting
times ahead of us a quick shout out to
experiment a startup to help research
projects come to fruition by
crowdsourcing them current experiments
include really cool projects like how we
could implement better anti-doping
policies for professional sports or how
to show in a computer screen how our
visual imagination works thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time